少し時間が押しておりますので
休憩時間を割愛させていただきまして
そのまま質疑応答の方に入りたいと思います
会場の方 挙手いただく形で質疑応答していきたいと思います
質問のある方は挙手していただけますでしょうか
よろしくお願いします
じゃあ質問させていただきます
ガンジス川におけるのお話
どうもありがとうございました
二つちょっとお聞きしたいんですけれども
一つは今日の講義の内容の限りではですね
日本には昔から儒教というのがあります
これは孔子の教えですけれども
道徳を中心に説いた教えなんです
で この儒教に対して先生はどのようにお考えになっていらっしゃるか
同じことなのか いや違うんだよ
違うとすれば どこ何が違うのかということが一つです
もう一つは 大乗仏教教典については先生はどういうふうにお考えになっていらっしゃるのか
この二点お話しいただければと思いますけど
あの孔子社ですね 孔子
孔子の教えについて  儒教っていうのは
ただまあもう社会の人間関係について語っているものでしょうね
もう まあ仏教でいう悟りとかね
心を清らかにするとかとかね
はないとは思いますけども
よく勉強してないからね
私はね よくわかりません （
笑）だから まあ世の中のシステムはしっかり守れて
親孝行してとかね まあなんか似てるようなんですけど
仏教はもっと厳密に分析してるんですね
もう一つですね  大乗仏教の教典についてどうお考えですか？ あーね
人の家の料理はどうでしょうかとか
私は （笑）例えばね フランス人はフランスパン食べてるんですけど
あなたどう思います？って勝手に食べればいいしね
で まあそういうことで
あの まあ大乗経典っていうのは
そのその宗派の宗教の方々は大事に信仰しているものですから
我々はやってないんですよ
私は公案を否定するし
認めませんし 新約聖書旧約聖書もゴミだと思っているし
それは私の勝手で そういうことではあんまり
あの まあ何とも言えませんね
勉強をさせたからできるわけでもなくて
あの やっぱりカンバスです
ですから 皆様方は一人一人大乗仏教を勉強なさっているならば
あの こういう風になりますけど
なんとか教えてください
だったら教えてあげることができます
自分で一人一人がそこら辺で判断なさった方がいいんじゃないかなと
私の仕事は 純粋にブッダの教えはこういうものであると紹介するだけ
どういうふうに受け取るかということは
皆様一人一人で自由にあります
はい そうです  どうもありがとうございます
では次の方 もう一人マイク持ちたい方でありらっしゃると思うんですけど
よろしくお願いします
三つあるんですけれど
もしあの善友と思える人が周りにいなくて
そういう人がいない場合は
あの現代においても サイの角のようにというか
一人で生きていった方を生きていけばいいんでしょうかということと
あと 善友というので性別はえっと
同性とか異性とかは問わないでしょうかということ
あと お釈迦様を善友としてはどうでしょうかって話があったんですけれど
お釈迦様っていうのはもう実際にもう亡くなられてリアルではいないんですけれど
これは具体的に言うとどういうことなんでしょうか
えーと なんか仏追念とか
そういうことをするとか
そういうことも善友って言えるのか
ということですね はい
私はボロ押し系のところはいたくまもなく喋りましたけどね
何も聞いてないところがあるので （
笑）早口で言ったんだからね
ちょっとポイントはちょっと残ってないところありますよ
あの 善友と親友に分けたんですね
善友っていうのはお釈迦様のことなの
だから性別は関係ないんです
でお釈迦様でなければ
悟りに達している方々ですから
そこの辺で言う人じゃないんですね
だから我々皆の善友はお釈迦様です
その前でお釈迦様は今いないでしょうけど
お釈迦様は実際にいても
皆様にはどうお元気ですか？とかね
それはできませんよ お釈迦様いた時にもさっさっと一人一人指導して指導して
もうものすごい早く行動していたんだから
そんなうかつにインドでもお釈迦様には会えなかったんです
アーナンダ尊者にお願いしてお願いして会わせてくださいと言わなきゃダメでしたからね
それでももうちゃんと修行して
大事な問題を持っている人しか会えない
お釈迦様忙しかったんです
だから肉体的に会うことは関係昔もなかったんです
ですから お釈迦様が言うのは
私が教えを残したでしょうに
完璧に完全無欠で語って残しました
これが私ですと だからブッダはいるんです
教えがあるたびに この教えがお釈迦様なんです
だからブッダの教典は我々の善友になるんです
残念ながら あれは本ですからね
男でも女でもないんです
中 何といいますか ニュートラルですね
しかし 修行の場合は別なんですね
修行っていうのは 皆様に毎日のいるいる仲間のことなんです
それはもう好き勝手でいいですよ
男でも女でもね 関係ないんです
修行っていうのは毎日いろいろ協力し合って
助け合って 話し合って
もういろいろお互い起きないでやって生きることでしょ
だから起きないでやっていくためには
まあそれぞれに性別で区別するということはあり得ないんです
はい その 2つですね ポイントは質問ですけど
質問に答えたんです はい
ありがとうございました
他に質問のある方挙手お願いします
たくさん上がりました
では 後ろの方の一番端の列の方
今日のテーマとは違うんですけど
希望の仕組みっていう本に書いてあった
あのプログラムを離脱する瞑想を教えてほしいんですけど
何が遠くなっちゃって言ってくれました
希望の仕組みという本の中で
プログラムを解脱する瞑想という記述があった
プログラムを 正面の話なんですけど
プログラムを分解する瞑想と書いてありました
プログラムを分解する瞑想法というのがあった
記述記述があったんですけど
ご記憶で  おそらく書いているのは
この我々が認識する過程の認識プログラムでは
ちょっとバグというかね
問題がありまして この愚痴という認識になりますからね
だからこのいくつでも愚痴を引き起こさせる
このプログラムを壊さなくちゃいけないんですね
それは普通の瞑想という意味なんですね
瞑想したらどうなるかというと
物事を見たり聞いたりする時の愚痴が生じることはなくなっちゃうんですね
ありのままに見える 今はありのままに見え
見えません 今もありのままに見たい
聞きたいんだけどできない
だからそれは壊すんですね
だから走りたい人がいて
足に鎖で足を縛ってあると走れないんですね
だからその鎖を破るんですね
やると走る そういうふうに我々認識プログラムが
あの ちょっとエラーが入ってるんですね
間違いというか バグというかね
それを改良するんです
それが瞑想ということなんです
もしかするとそれがそれ言ってると思います
はい わかりました  では
その前の手が挙げていた方お願いします
本日はありがとうございます
あの 瞑想するときにですね
ブッダの彫刻 お像を前に拝みますが
ブッダのお像というのは善運になるんでしょうか
それと あの 仏像というのはどういう存在とお考えになったりでしょうか
また あの仏師が仏像を作る時にはどういう気持ちで作らなくてはいけないんでしょうか
以上です  仏像はね まあそんなに真剣に考えなくてもね
いいと思いますけど まあそれは宗派によって違いますけど
例えば大乗仏教の華厳ではね
仏像 様々な仏像があって信仰がありましてね
あの仏像を触ってはかんとかね
魂入れるとか 魂抜けるとかね
いろいろアニミスティックたくさんありますけど
初期仏教ではないんですね
仏教ではただの石だから
美しいからっていう感じで
まあそれほどの信心はないんですね
仏像を作る場合は やっぱりブッダを表現する芸術作品なので
好き勝手使って作ってはいけないんですね
本当にその作品を見てから心が安らかになるから
慈しみが感じるのか 安穏
安寧平安感じるのかということが芸術的な腕なんですね
だから仏像を作る時の心構えっていうのは
見た人の心がおでん顔になること
安穏を感じさせることで慈しみを感じさせることなんです
仏像を作る時の心はそんな程度なんです
仏像はそんなに 瞑想する時
仏像の前でなくても後ろでやっても構いませんし
それとはもう全然関係ないですね
ただ 歴史と長い歴史の中で
まあある文化的な習慣として
誰でも仏像は好きなんですね
それほど大げさな問題ではないです
ただ 仏像は好き それだけ
その宗教的な意味合いはないんです
ブッダの教えがブッダなんです
我々はブッダを生で実感したければ
ブッダの教えをずっと読んで理解することなんです
そうするとなんとなくブッダを自分の前でいるのことも実感できますよ
それはあくまでも抽象的なんですね
理解することがね よ ダンマンパッサティソウマンパッサティっていうのはブッダの言葉なんですね
誰かが真理を理解するならば
その人が私を見ているんだ
ということで ブッダと接近した人
したい人はブッダの教えを学ぶしかないんです
教え学ぶと本当にもうなんか自分の心の一番そばにいる存在のように感じるんです
母親と同じく感じるんです
いつでもそばにいるんだと
何かあったらすぐいるんだと
だから母親っていうのは
皆様が外国に行っても
困った時はすぐ耳元で何か言ってくれますからね
電話しただけででも電話は遠いかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり母の言葉はいつでも心のそばにあるんだからね
そういうふうに仏教を理解すると
ブッダが一番そばにいる存在になります
ブッダを経験したりする場合は
仏教を理解する仏像が別ならなんです
それはもうあなたは音楽好きですか？踊る好きですか？ということでもうどちらでもよろしいですからね
勝手なものですね はい
それでは こちらの列の女性の方
中ほどの女性の方お願いします
あ あの ちょっと後ろの方だけだったんですけど
すいません 貴重なお話ありがとうございました
えっとですね 素朴な質問なんですけども
深淵についてお伺いしたいと思います
実生活でその ...友人っていう友人関係っていうのが
どうしてもその協力とか無関関係よりも打算的とか
あと嫉妬とか そういうなんていうんですか
そういう利害関係にもとづいてしまうんですけども
そう それをどうやったら協力とか
そういう無害的な関係に持っていけるっていうのをかいうのかをちょっとお伺いしたいんですけど
まあでも何でもかんでも我々が完璧に理想的にね
いこうと思わなければいいでしょ
例えば理想的な人間関係なんてありえないの
どんな人間関係でもどこかでいつもね
ガタガタガタガタするんですよ
だからそれもありえない
まあだからまあほどほどよく
お互い人間関係を取った方がよろしいんです
例えば会社に行ったら人間関係
しかし あまりしつこく何かしたくないならば
ほどほどに 仕事のやってる間はすごくニコニコと笑って丁寧に挨拶をして
仕事終わったらはい さようならって逃げちゃえばいい
で そういう風にあの その場その場の人間関係もあるし
まあ利害関係ではなくて
柔軟性の関係でなければいけないです
自分に害を与える関係はやっぱり避けた方がいいですね
嫉妬 憎しみばっかり絡んでる関係もできるだけ避けた方がいいです
誰かと友達になるとどうも嫉妬してしまうならば
やはり友達関係を切った方がいいんです
もう心が汚れますからね
それは最悪です というわけで
このあまりこの嫉妬 怒り
憎しみばっかりの関係はもうできるだけ避けてください
完璧に避けられませんよ
それでも それでもいくらが付き合わなくちゃいけないことになります
だいたい柔軟性関係 私は人を助けてあげる
その人も私も何かあったら助けてくれるという関係ですね
夫婦関係もそういうのでしょ
そういう関係でお互いに協力し合う関係は正しい人間関係なんです
いくらなんでも どんな人間関係においても不満というものは出ます
ないわけではないです
ああ そんなもんかっていう風な程度で終わることは思います
完璧なぴったしの関係っていうのは
これは珍しいですよ もうほとんどありえない
何かなんですよ これさえなければいい人間
人なのにとかね あるでしょ
いつでも あなたの旦那はいかがでしょう？ああ
すごくいい人です でもこれさえなければ
そういう風な何かなんて誰にでもありますから
それは気にしないことです
はい  ありがとうございます
あ すいません 今喋りかけ
話しかけた方が えっと
今マイクがありませんので
ちょっとお待ちください
あ あのですね 今日のお話ともちょっと関係ないことでお聞きしたいんですけど
古代インド人が理想とした四慈愛のことについてちょっと知りたいんですね
私も 70に近い だからもう私はより大きいに近づいたのかな
それとも臨時的なのかな
今とってもだろ 心がなんか寂しい
虚しい 不安をちょっとなんかこう抱えてるんですね
それをどうあの コントロールしたらいいのかっていうので
ちょっと先生にお聞きした今日来てるんですけど
はい あのね 古代と現代ってどれぐらいですかね
古代って何年たてばいいですかね
こんなボタンの上げ方計算ついてくると
この修行期の考えっていうのはね
特に良くないんですよ
世界中考えて続くかもですね
それはどうでもいいんだ
人間が作るものだからね
修行期とかなんとかとかね
もう仏教はそういう馬鹿にしてますよ
はっきりいい加減にしろ
人は修行したくなったら
どんな時でもいいじゃないですかね
そんなのはプログラム書くのはね
もうあまりにもズレてね
とにかく我々はどんどん年取ってくると虚しくもなるし
怖くもなるし これまた逆に避けられないんです
それからこのどんどん人生面白くなくなっていくんですね
別に面白くあれも面白くないと
あれもこれも面白くないと言うのはいいんだけど
では あなたは私は何したいのかと自分に聞いたら
それもないんですね これやることもないし
やりたいこともないし
やることないんだから面白くはないし
面白くやることはないしという最悪の状態になるんですね
最悪の状態には  なってない
これからなります だから
この 我々は常にこういう風にね
考えるんですよ あの やっぱり人間の仕事っていうのは
清らかな心を作ることなんですね
いつでも清らかな心でいるんだぞと
例えば体の調子がどんどん悪くなっていく
そうすると一緒に心も落ち込んでいくんですね
それをさせない あ 病気だ
体が壊れていきなさい
しかし 私はさらに忍耐があって
明るい心でいるんだぞと
子供たちは出て行く はい
どうぞ出て行ってください
私は明るく落ち着いているんだぞ
で どんどん一人ぼっちになって構いませんと
自分がもういろいろ一人でどうやって生活すればよろしいかというふうに
この無常の世界の中でね
体も無常で変化している中で
いかに心の安らぎと清らかさを保つのかということは
人間の勝負どころなんですね
だからまあ それやってみると結構忙しいんですね
こうあれやこのちょっと心配とかね
ちょっと恐怖感とか感じて
そんなこと言ってる場合じゃなくなっちゃうんですね
ああ 仕事あるんだ 仕事あるんだっていうことでね
友達と喋る時でも まあいろいろいろんな頼み事をするでしょうね
その時はいかにいかにお手上げいるのかとかね
心の中での修行っていうのをやるべきなんですね
で 大体あの そういうことはもう年取ってくるとね
年取っていったってもね
まあ中年過ぎてくると
もう大体あまり責任は任してくれませんね
もうどうぞどうぞ自由にしてくださいとかね
追い出されますね こっちでやりますからとかね
こっちより別にできるんだけどね
だからまあ それはそれで別に気にしないで
我々は心を成長するんですね
人には学ぶことは死ぬ瞬間まであります
で それでお釈迦様は推薦してます
今更ピアノの演奏を学んでもね
バイオリンの弾き方をどのように弾くかというのは役に立ちませんし
バカバカらしいし だから心清らかです
嫉妬しないように 怒らないように
欲張らないように 舞い上がらないように
興奮しないようにということで
心の修行はするんです
で その場合はどんどん人生が楽しくなっていくんです
はい  ありがとうございました
この間 真ん中の方々が
真ん中の列の方で一番前の男性の方
すいません よろしくお願いいたします
今日のお話で 善意がいることは仏道においてすべてであるというように
お釈迦様は善意の重要性について語られているわけですが
えっと 私たちにとって善意はお釈迦様で
お釈迦様が悟られる前に
どなたかお釈迦様いて
善意と言える方がいらっしゃったんでしょうか
私は勉強不足で申し訳ないのですが
修行時代は尼さんの師に
学ばれたと言っても すぐ学ばれて
基本一人で学ばれたイメージがあるのですが
どういったいらっしゃったのかなというふうに
今日の話を聞いて思いました
論理的には人間にはね
やっぱり師匠が必須なんですね
師匠がなく学ぶことはできないんです
お釈迦様も出家して同じ論理で
私は誰から学ぼうかなといって
いろんな弟子にしたんです
弟子にして 僧侶 先生たちが達している最高の境地に達してみたんですね
しかし お釈迦様には個人的な宿題があったんですね
存在の問題は完全に解決したい
それで あの 今までの先生たちがどこで間違っていたのかっていうところを発見しちゃったんですね
それをお釈迦様 自分一人で発見しちゃうんですね
だからお釈迦様はだけをちょっと必ずしも特別な存在なんです
我々とは違いますね しかし
お釈迦様も我々と同じく
いろんな先生たちのところに行って
弟子入りをして教えを学んだんです
しかし お釈迦様がおっしゃった教えはどこにもないんです
新しいお釈迦様が発見したものなんです
だから世の中にはもう我々はないんだ
一人しか それぐらい人格者がね
それもお釈迦様が生まれて持ったというよりは
自分がもう修行して発見したものだからね
悟って生まれたわけではない
生まれてから悟りに出したんです
だからお釈迦様だけ もう例外と言ったっても
完璧に例外ではないんです
ちょっと桁違いというかね
そんな程度なんですね
あの大学の中に入って研究するときでも
一応あの大学勉強研究する場合は
まあ教授に過ぎてはいるんだけど
やっぱり教授のありがたさを受けますけど
やっぱり自分が新しいものなんか発見して
研究をして出しちゃいますでしょ
だから本当に基本的には何かやってて
何もやってくれてないんです
ただ そこら辺で今いただけでね
そういう感じでね まああの
我々も時々あの誰かの教授のところにはいるんだけど
自分の勉強は自分でする場合もあります
それはできるのはやっぱり一流になってからなんです
小学生にはできない 中学生にも大学生にもできない
大学院でももうちょっと進んで
研究員になってから なんとなくやっとできそうになるような感じなんですね
だからお釈迦様も普通の人々のところでね
学んでもらったんだけど
全部終わってから自分の道を自分で発見したんです
しかし 人類にはやっぱり善用がないと進めないということは
なんかすごい条件のようにあるんですね
善意っていうのは明らかにお釈迦様のことなんで
それはあの あまり無茶苦茶にしないでください
他の方々のことは仲間とかね
まあ親友とかね ということになるんです
だから仲間だから喧嘩したっても構いませんし
気に入らなかったら捨てたっても構いませんし
それはそんなに大げさなことじゃないんです
仲間の場合は このあまりたくさん作っちゃってね
みんな 面倒見ることで自分の人生ダメになるとこまで行ったわけだ
自分のプライドも自分の自由も守りつつ
友達関係を持つという
この自分の能力の範囲で友達を作るんですね
そんな程度ですね はい
頑張ってください  わかりました
ありがとうございます
それでは真ん中の列で少し後ろの方の方で上げてくれたら
じゃあ少し あの じゃあその方が
真ん中の方のおばあちゃんでございます
はい 本日ありがとうございました
ちょっとお聞かせください
私ももう後期高齢者近づいていろいろ考えちゃうんですけども
日本の仏教は あの仏教っていうのは我々信徒はですね
江戸時代に檀家制度があって
全部大乗仏教の中に組み入れられて現在あるわけでございますけども
その中で檀家というものがありましてですね
自分のところのお墓の大抵を持ってるわけでございます
それであのお寺さんがやれることはですね
先祖供養とか追善供養とか
そういうようなことでいろいろお金を儲けているわけでございますけども
本当に先祖供養とか追善供養なんていうものはできるものか
それで あの今のスリランカの仏教ではそういうものに対してどうやって考えているのか
その辺をお聞きしたいと思います
よろしくお願いします
そういう習慣は習慣もスリランカではないですから
スリランカでは何も考えてないんです
それはないんです  日本ではね
日本なりの文化を作ってるんだから
それについてね 私が外人でね
何も言う権利はないでしょうしね
そういう先祖供養 追善供養などっていうのは
別に仏教っていうわけじゃないんです
そういう習慣は仏教的に行っているだけ
例えば結婚は仏教がどうっていうことじゃなくて
仏教があろうがなかろうが
人々は結婚する それで
じゃあ仏教的に結婚式やりましょうということは可能でしょ
だから人間がやってるあらゆる習慣
しきたりは 後で仏教的にやるということはあり得ることですね
例えば先祖崇拝というね
四十九日ですね それはもう仏教のところじゃなくて
遠い昔から日本でやっていたことで
それで仏教が入ってきてからは
まあせっかく仏教があることので
じゃあ仏教的にやりましょうということになるんですね
そういうことで 日本ではこういう四十九日ですね
調子とかなんとかとかね
それが仏教的にやるようになりまして
だからそれには仏教の教えも使ったりするとね
坊の話とかね 輪廻の話は必要ですけど
日本の仏教は輪廻の話はあまり気にしない
捨ててますね あの まあ一番立場がよろしいですよ
知らないものは捨てた方がね
勉強しない人いますが
まあそういうことで あまり輪廻のことを考えていないし
輪廻のことを考えちゃうと
先祖供養で浄土しまったってことはまずいだからね
で まあそれいろいろ文化に左右なんですね
あのテーラワーダ仏教から言えば
この初期仏教から言えば
やっぱりあの供養は可能ですけど
まあそれはいつでもできることで
我々は良いことをして
あの みんなにもみんなに利己をする程度の話なんですね
かなり考えています すごい軽々しく考えています
すごい真剣ではないんです
向こうの仏教では やはり人は自分の思考は自分の責任である
だから一人一人があんた自分死んでからどうするのかと
ちょっとそれも考えておけよ
死んでからどうする必要もないんだけど
もう念のために良いことをしておくと
死亡があるかどうか今さらわからないし
あってもなくても痛いことやって死んじゃうとね
どうせまずいと決まってるし
ですから やっぱりまあ
できる範囲で善行をして
個人個人が生きている
それが仏教の普通のやり方なんですね
それで 我々は親が死んじゃったらもうね
幸福でありますようにと
で そこはまあ何か法事をやって祝います
それは別に祝わなくちゃなんです
親亡くなったらまあ結構法要をやります
それはなんかどっちかというとちょこっとした死儀礼みたいなものなんです
悲しいことでもなんでもなくて
もうそれは親を思って
親について 親の幸福を願ってやっている法要であると
それが必ずしも親に行くかどうかというのは
全然誰にも聞こうともしないし
そんなに厳しいではないです
我々が説法する場合はね
この親の三 三ヶ月間の亡くなって 三十日間の法事かもしれませんだけどね
この男はお母さんに行くかもしれませんし
行かないかもしれませんよっていうんです
そんなのわかったものじゃないよ
それで信者さんが あ そう
では取り消しますとはないんです
そこまではないんです
それはもうずっとやっていることだから
必ずやる しかし 私が死後幸福になるだければ
これ私個人の宿題でやります
それだけは発見しています
そこはあの日本とも日本もそういうことをやった方がいいんじゃない？一人一人日本人があの
お寺のお経をお金もらって天国に行かせてもらうよりは
やっぱり俺がその保証書を取った方がいいんだと自分で
やっぱり自分一人一人で自分の死後を保証した方がよろしいんじゃないんですかね
だって日本の仏教習慣っていうのは派手に変わっちゃいますよ
あの今はね なんかビルの中でしょ
お位牌とかあるの それでコンピューターで自分の暗証番号と自分の登録番号を入れると
その下からガラガラガラガラお位牌が上がってくるんですね
そこでお坊さんが それでお坊さんがいないとお金払っちゃえば
あの IC で録音してお経が流れて
時間が終わったらガラガラガラですね
あんなものになっちゃったらかわいそう
オートで何が起きるんですかね
まあやっぱり社会っていうのはそういうふうに馬鹿げたことにどんどん変わっていくし
だから念のために一人一人の死後が幸福になりますように
今から清らかな心で良いことをしながら生活して
やっぱり自分の手に自分の将来の保証書を取った方がいいんです
あの日を持ってるんじゃないってことはダメなんです
あの権利書を自分で取った方がよろしいですね
そういうことをそんな程度ですね
私の言いたいところはそういうものです
ありがとうございました
では 後ろの今しゃべりかけてしまった方
女性の方にお話しください
瞑想について伺いたいと思います
お願いします 今年の春にヴィパッサナー瞑想を教わったんですけれども
歩く瞑想をそれからずっと続けていますが
先生が歩く瞑想は大変因果がよくわかるとおっしゃったんです
それはどういうことなんだろうと
いつも読みながら考えているんですけれども
教えていただければと思います
歩く瞑想は  歩く瞑想は因果が大変よくわかる
因果  ああ はい  お願いします
もうちょっとやってみてください
あの やっぱりもしね 休みの日とかね
1時間  1時間  1時間とかね ５
6回  7回ぐらい続けてやってみると
あの智慧が現れる可能性がすごくあるんです
因果がわかります より
これ説明しちゃっても意味がないんですね
自分で発見することだからね
はい 別にするものは何もないんです
必ず因と果と因果 因と果の関係というのは見えてきます
見えてくるとどんどん自我という幻が幻想がね
本当に薄れていくんですよ
ただあるだけ もうちょっと経験頑張ってみてください
はい ありがとうございました
それでは真ん中の席の中央の方の方
すみません 手挙げていただけますか
今日はどうもありがとうございました
私は 1年ぐらい前に本屋さんで先生の本を見つけてですね
それを読み始めてからどんどん興味が出てまいりまして
講演会も今日で 3回目なんですけれども
私は先生の書かれた中で一番初めに印象に残ったのはですね
人間は必ず生まれたら必ず死ぬというのは誰も否定できない真理であると
で いつまでも生きておれる
生きていくことができるという妄想のもとに人間が生きていると
あと その生まれてから死ぬまで
どんどんどんどん変化
日々一日一刻一刻変化していくのが無常であり
一刻とも一刻たりとも変化しないものはないということが気づくことが無常であると
それについてですね いろいろ物事が変化していることについて
自分に都合のいい変化をすることに人間は喜んで
自分に都合の悪い変化については怒りが生じると
で この世に生まれたことは苦であって
その根源は怒りから始まるので
その怒りを抑えることが苦をなくすことであるというところからですね
もうどんどん興味が増してですね
その怒りを抑えることによって苦がなくなるというところら辺まで来まして
今まで宗教に対して持っているそういう感覚ではなくて
非常に論理的で否定できないものがあるということで
先生の話を伺っているんですけれども
結局ですね その衣食住とかですね
名誉とか財産とか地位とか
そういうものはいくら持っていても
その死んで墓場まで持っていけるものでもないということで
そういう欲望を抑えることで苦がなくなるということまではなんとなく理解はできたんですけども
それについてですね このヴィパッサナーですか
私はまだその瞑想というのは
先生のあのビデオ DVD で見て
それを真似て 1 日 10 分ずつぐらいやっているだけなんですけれども
それをやることによってですね
あの 生きとし生けるものが幸せになりますようにという
それに続くお祈りの言葉があって
それで心が安らぐことで欲望がなくなっていって
苦は欲がなくなることによって苦もなくなるというふうで考えてよろしいでしょうか？それともう一つはですね
あの 死ぬことは決してつらいことではなくて
生きていることの方がずっと苦しくてですね
死んだ人の顔が非常に安らいだ顔で死んでいると
死んだ後 安らいだ顔になっているということも書かれていたんですけども
そういうことはまあ自分で死を選ぶということはなんとなくよくないという
自殺のことなんですけども
よくないというふうに思うんですけども
それについてはどうなんですかね
それで あと 生きているからには苦がなくなって安らかにいる方がいいということも
誰もが考えることなんですけども
それを目指すために欲望というものをできるだけ減らして
それに反比例して苦も減っていくと
比例して減っていくという考え方でよろしいでしょうか
まだ私は初心者でよくわかってないけど
ですね 考えっていうのは全部仏教ではダメだと言ってるんですよ
あの何を仏教のことででも考えて何か決めちゃうと
それ自体もまた根拠になっちゃってね
かえって苦しみが新たな苦しみが増えるだけなんですね
まあとにかくこの欲望をなくせ
欲望をなくすということで決しなくても
あの智慧が現れてほしいんですね
智慧っていうのは ありのままに修行しられる能力ですね
それもこう まあ修行しなくてはちょっと出てこないんですけどね
これは心にあるマインドコントロール
完全に高めるしかないんですね
それはヴィパッサナーの実践でマインドコントロールは全部消えてしまって
ありのままに見えるようになりかかってきます
それは智慧というんですね
この智慧が現れると あの大概煩悩というものっていうのはもう適当に減って消えていくんですね
煩悩だけを腹が立って怒鳴り散らしても
かえって煩悩が増えるだけ
意味がないんです 感情をいじっちゃうと
感情が増えれば増えるんで増えるんですよ
感情はもともと平気ですからね
例えば食べ物に目が無い人がいると
欲でしょ 食べたい食べたいというね
なんでお前食べたいじゃない
理屈じゃないんですね
感情ですから グルメであれやこれやと食べ歩きする
その人は突然 今日から食べることをやめますと
節制な食事です 無理です
そんなまあ 1 週間ぐらい頑張るでしょう
それそれから食うとも感情が湧いてくるんですね
でも怒らないようにと頑張っちゃうと
かえって怒ってしまうんですね
そういうことはありますよね
感情とは迂闊に遊べないんです
だから もともと感情に理性がないんです
それで仏教が説明するのは
あの物事は無常であって
因果法則であって 消え
生まれては消え 生まれては消え
生まれては消え その流れでしょうと
だからもうそこで執着するには値するものではないっていう智慧がついてくると
ああ 怒る怒りがなくなっているわ
欲望がなくなっているわということになるんですね
あらまさ目隠しじゃくて足りないんですね
欲望はないんだと そういうふうに
正しく心理学的になくなっていくんです
踏ん張っただけではなられません
踏ん張っちゃうとかえって悪くなる可能性はどうしてもあります
それから それ心にとってはすごいストレスですからね
それはしません そういったことで手取る感じで瞑想実践
ヴィパッサナー実践というのをやった方がよろしいんです
それをやってみると 心理が見えてきて
必ず心は清らかになります
ヴィパッサナー実践はちゃんとやり方は本から学んでも
それほど通じていないところもありますので
ただ個人的に指導受けた方がいい
結果は早いとは思います
慈悲の瞑想ね 一つ一つ申し訳ありませんなどなどという祈りではありませんよ
祈りは反対です 仏教は誰も何もお願いしてるわけじゃないんです
それはもう自分の心の中で慈しみを繁殖するんです
移植して繁殖するんです
あれ作業です 一つ大事に
作業です 心の中でとことん慈しみを育ててあげるんです
決して祈りじゃないんです
それだけ覚えてください
はい